what's going on guys my name is David
Tommy Sherman welcome back to the
channel today we're talking about the
two kings of the e-commerce game we're
talking about the Squarespace and we're
talking about Shopify
the main purpose of today's video is to
find out which one is the best for you
and which one is the king of e-commerce
in 2019 if you're new to the channel and
are wondering what gives this guy the
credentials to even be making this video
well my name is Dave atomic as I've
already said I'm an entrepreneur in 2019
and I've successfully launched three
different companies internationally my
greatest achievement so far has been
wire watches this company is now stocked
in fourteen stores across three
continents and has sold out of multiple
collections for me why watch is
originally started on wicks transition
through Squarespace and ended up on
Shopify
not to give anything away but it did end
on Shopify for a reason I want to make
sure that you guys make the best
informed opinion about which platform is
right for you and right for your brand
it doesn't matter if you're doing an
e-commerce store or if you're building
any other sort of website Squarespace
for starters gives you the flexibility
and the templates to create anything
from a photography page to a videography
page ecommerce store or even just your
general blog with hundreds of difference
of templates available at your
fingertips Squarespace gives you the
freedom and luxury to create almost
anything that your heart desires without
having to know a single line of code
this is something that gives Squarespace
a huge leg up over Shopify shop fire
doesn't have this many options it has
eight free templates and sixty-four paid
templates which range anywhere from 140
us to 180 us if you're brand new to the
e-commerce game Squarespace
again has the leg up over Shopify it's
such an easy to use platform and you can
get started and have a website live
within just a couple of hours it doesn't
require you don't know any coding it
does
why do you have any and I mean any
background website building knowledge as
long as you know how to use the basics
of a computer you can pretty much
guarantee that you're going to be able
to build a Squarespace website within
the next couple days and if you're
already experienced more than likely
within the next couple of hours a
shortfall of Squarespace is a simple
fact that if your company is quite large
and you're already delivering millions
of units every single year then you go
ahead and have a Black Friday sale like
we did receive hundreds of orders out of
nowhere thousands and thousands and
thousands if not millions of clicks per
second you end up with a too much
traffic Squarespace and their back-end
infrastructure can't support it this is
pretty prevalent in the simple fact when
you look at a price guide their most
expensive ecommerce platform is 52
Australian dollars or 35 u.s. for their
premium top-of-the-range advanced
ecommerce package now when you take a
look at Shopify which has been
specifically designed just for
e-commerce so you can't go ahead I guess
you can if you wanted to but you
wouldn't go ahead and build like a blog
or a photography page on there that
doesn't sell anything
Shopify offers the premium 299 dollar US
dollar per month package for assistance
of all your e-commerce needs and if your
store has grown well beyond the 299 US
dollar needs and capacity of what shops
I can offer you there they also offer
you a by invite-only package deal that
helps you save a little bit of money and
also gives you full time
around-the-clock support especially
during Black Friday and Cyber Monday
so Squarespace is fantastic for doing
website and it's really simple and
really easy to use why would you go to
shop fight if you're just a small brand
and all you're just starting out well
the answer again there is relatively
simple Shopify has been designed for
e-commerce it doesn't matter what kind
of ecommerce store you're running if
you're looking to sell a product their
physical or digital this is the website
that's catered exactly to your needs
simple shortfall is the fact that your
website is probably going to look
exactly the same as everybody else's
because they're so limited three
templates out there you only have eight
to choose from so chances are your
website's going to look exactly like Bob
James and John's down the street because
there is only eight but this isn't
exactly the worst thing in the world
these templates have been tried tested
and improved upon every single year
which makes them perfect for selling
ecommerce product online in 2019 another
leg up that Shopify has over Squarespace
is the fact that it has thousands of
integrated apps that you can simply
integrate into your website with a
single click there isn't too much coding
involved most of the time there's none
it automatically does everything for you
and if there is a little bit of coding
involved most of those apps actually
offer a dedicated service to code it
automatically for you
so if you're looking to add a tracking
app or maybe a postage app or something
just to really talk to your customers
you can very easily and very quickly do
it through Shopify whereas in
Squarespace it's a bit more of an
exercise and you're very limited in the
amount of options you have to access
these apps and to access these services
if you look at it on the other hand shop
flyer does have all these apps which
means it has an overwhelming amount of
information it's designed for e-commerce
and it's designed for people who know
how to use e-commerce tools so if you
don't know anything about analytics
about marketing or even how to run a
basic store then Shopify has a very big
learning curve because it expects you to
understand how everything works if you
want to direct customers to your website
and make some sales which at the end of
the day is everybody's goal that's
getting on Shopify in my personal
experience I found that the SEO
integration behind-the-scenes that you
don't have to worry about on both
platforms is a lot stronger and Shopify
as well your website appears in a lot
more places a lot quicker and ranks
higher in google based on the simple
fact that it's transitioned from Shopify
to Squarespace I know without having to
do any additional marketing when we
moved our websites over from week's to
Squarespace to Shopify sales simply
continue to increase
is a fantastic website builder
Squarespace is a fantastic website
builder but then Shopify is directly
targeted at this market so it allowed
Google to know exactly what the store
was and it knew exactly who the
customers were so when people were
searching they were targeting exactly
the right words and finding the store a
lot quicker so again in my experience
Shopify had the much better SEO behind
in the background that you don't have to
worry about too much and you don't have
to stress about all day every day one of
the main things people look for when
they're actually starting out a new
e-commerce brand and have no idea about
each platform or have just started
researching it is a simple financial
investment required Squarespace is
significantly cheaper than Shopify shop
flies most basic plan is 43 Australian
dollars or 29 us
whereas 452 Australian dollars or 35 us
you can get the most premium
top-of-the-range support services
abandoned cards absolutely everything on
Squarespace this for most people is a
no-brainer you go Squarespace it does
the same thing it's able to do the same
thing I'm gonna be able to sell my
products really quickly and it's half
the price or if you think about it like
you do with tech if you go out and buy a
$10 item that you know should cost about
a hundred and you take it home you start
using it you're gonna see it fail and
you're gonna see some folks really
really quickly it's still probably gonna
work it's still probably gonna do the
job but it's definitely not going to do
the job as well as that hundred dollar
item so this is the same way you can
think about these two competitors
they're both fantastic in their own
right but Shopify has the utensils and
has the ability to really take your
business to the next level so if you
were to get my serious honest opinion
and keeping in mind that this video is
in no way shape or form sponsored by
either of the two it's just my honest
opinion my honest ramble about both
websites about how they both perform and
how they can both impact your business
personally regardless of the size of
your business if you're looking to
invest your time your energy your money
and your hard work into this company
business
you want to call it and you want it to
succeed it's something you really really
desire then well the obvious choice is
shop flight you start your shop up on
Shopify you take the financial hit at
the start but it will pay off in the
long run in my experience if you're
putting in the hard yards nobody's gonna
come to your website no matter what
platform you build it if you don't
advertise it if you don't market it and
if you don't know what you're doing SEO
is alone at the start they won't get you
anywhere you need to have some traffic
coming into the website you need to be
on Google long enough to actually start
ranking and you need to be continuously
providing content for that website
that's all for me today guys thank you
so much for watching if you enjoyed the
video make sure you smash that subscribe
button
20:19 start almost 2020 and as always
I'll see you next Monday